el 8 de noviembre de 2016 donald trump
ganó las elecciones presidenciales de
eeuu contra todo pronóstico no vamos a
intentar aparentar que somos imparciales
si queréis podéis pinchar en nuestra
playlist dedicada a las elecciones
americanas de 2016 para ver cuál es
nuestra opinión sobre donald trump y
cuál era el candidato al que nosotros
apoyábamos sin embargo y aunque nos
duela tenemos que reconocer que la
campaña de donald trump ha sido
brillante y la prueba es que ha ganado
por supuesto si habéis seguido las
elecciones desde medios de comunicación
europeos o latinoamericanos haber
recibido una imagen totalmente distinta
a la que han tenido los ciudadanos
estadounidenses que en última instancia
son los que tienen que votar y
precisamente por eso muchos os estaréis
preguntando cómo es posible que donald
trump haya ganado las elecciones
hoy os lo vamos a explicar
la derecha alternativa muchos califican
a donald trump como simplemente un
conservador muy radical alguien que ha
tomado los principios del partido
republicano y los ha llevado al extremo
nada más lejos de la realidad lo cierto
es que el presidente electo se ha creado
su propia ideología y esto no lo digo yo
lo reconoce él mismo el sunset from de
riquer como dije al principio esto no ha
sido una campaña sino un movimiento
político y os preguntaréis cómo se puede
crear una ideología desde cero pues bien
existe toda una teoría política para
ello lo primero que tenemos que hacer es
encontrar distintas causas políticas que
no están representadas por ningún
partido por ejemplo los votantes
cristianos evangélicos ya están
representados por los políticos
tradicionales del partido republicano
así que no nos valen
sin embargo existe toda una clase obrera
blanca que trabaja en el sector de la
automoción en ciudades industriales como
detroit que perdió su trabajo durante la
crisis financiera de 2008 muchas
fábricas cerraron la producción y la
trasladaron a china así que es normal
que este grupo culpe a los chinos de su
mala situación por otro lado tenemos a
ese grupo de votantes resentido con los
inmigrantes mexicanos que han sido
capaces de salir adelante e incluso en
muchos casos montar sus propias empresas
y terminar ganando más dinero que los
votantes blancos tradicionales todos
estos sectores existían pero estaban
totalmente huérfanos de representación
política bien porque se pensaba que eran
demasiado radicales y que espantarían a
otros votantes o bien simplemente porque
se creía que eran grupos muy reducidos
por ejemplo en eeuu nadie se atreve a
pronunciar esa palabra que empieza por n
y que solamente pueden decir los raperos
sin embargo nadie tiene ningún problema
en minusvalorar a los paletos los
rednecks y los kill bill y que son en
esencia blancos de clase media-baja y
esta corrección política también ha
irritado a muchos votantes sin embargo
quién iba a pensar que una cosa tan
estúpida como una simple palabra pudiera
ser determinante para que mucha gente se
decantará por un candidato
pues bien donald trump cogió todas esas
causas y las aglutina en lo que en
teoría política se conoce como un
significante vacío y os preguntaréis que
es un significante vacío pues es una
palabra tan genérica que puede
significar lo que cada uno quiera por
ejemplo el eslogan de donald trump hacer
que américa vuelva a ser grande otra vez
puede significar lo que cada uno quiera
para algunos la américa grande significa
una américa libre de inmigrantes para
otros es una américa que no comercia con
china es decir es una expresión tan
bonita como vacía y por eso cada uno la
llena con el significado que le interesa
y os preguntaréis pero esto realmente
funciona la gente no se da cuenta de que
donald trump le está diciendo a cada uno
lo que quiere oír pues bien un elemento
imprescindible para crear un movimiento
político es elegir a un antagonista los
que seguís este canal desde hace tiempo
me lo habréis oído decir mil veces uno
se define por su opuesto en el caso de
trump tenemos a un enemigo interno que
serían los inmigrantes mexicanos y el
establishment político representado por
hillary clinton pero también existiría
un enemigo externo que sería china y el
terrorismo islámico gracias al
antagonista trump nos crea una identidad
sus votantes se sienten parte de algo y
por eso justifican cualquier declaración
o cualquier impertinencia que haya
soltado el candidato durante la campaña
y sí pero esperad un momento porque hay
algo más el broche de oro de la campaña
de trump ha sido esa propuesta estrella
de la que hemos hablado todos el muro en
la frontera entre eeuu y méxico
por supuesto se trata de algo tan
estúpido como irrealizable pero desde el
punto de vista del marketing político es
una auténtica obra maestra algo similar
a la conquista de la luna que propuso
kennedy en los años 60 para conquistar
el corazón de sus votantes y porque es
una propuesta tan poderosa primero
porque es algo tangible frente a
cualquier propuesta fiscal que es un
concepto abstracto el muro es algo que
podemos visualizar todos nos podemos
imaginar un muro además se presenta como
una solución muy sencilla para un
problema muy concreto que la gente cree
que existe
es que es un proyecto lo suficientemente
grande como para ilusionar a los
votantes si se construyera se trataría
de una de las mayores obras de
ingeniería de la historia y eso es
ilusionante de por sí gracias a todos
estos elementos
donald trump ha sido capaz de
cristalizar una ideología a la que se le
ha llamado derecha alternativa y que de
hecho tiene su propio medio de
comunicación de referencia que es este
portal que veis aquí que se llama brain
back
este periódico online se ha convertido
en el órgano de difusión de la campaña
de trump y en menos de dos años ha
logrado construir una audiencia superior
a la del huffington post el new york
times' y como veis es un auténtico
panfleto no tenéis más que ver su
portada el día de las elecciones vamos
que sólo les faltó decir hemos ganado
brave art es algo así como la razón pero
con lectores
quien ha votado a trump uno de los
estereotipos más difundidos por los
medios no estadounidenses es que trump
se ha ganado el corazón de los llamados
hillbillies esos americanos blancos de
clase media-baja que viven en la zona
central del país pero es esto del todo
cierto se puede caricaturizar al votante
medio de donald trump como una especie
de cletus es para claire
realmente las encuestas post electorales
reflejan que le han votado el 63 por
ciento de los hombres blancos el doble
de los que han votado a hillary clinton
y eso incluye a gente que estudia la
universidad y que tiene trabajos
cualificados lo mismo ocurre con las
mujeres el 53 por ciento de las mujeres
blancas han votado a trump en realidad
los únicos segmentos donde el oponente
de trump hillary clinton ha conseguido
ganar han sido las minorías raciales y
aún así ha habido una gran sorpresa
los hispanos si la mayoría ha votado a
hillary pero no tanto como se esperaba
y es que estos han dado un mayor apoyo a
trump ya romney en las pasadas
elecciones de 2012 la llave que tenían
los hispanos en estados como florida ha
acabado girando a favor de trump esto
puede explicarse en que muchos de ellos
ciudadanos legales con derecho a voto
pueden ver a los que están en situación
irregular como una competencia laboral
de la que trump pueden librar les
personalmente más allá de ideologías
creo que es difícil de justificar que un
hispano decida votar a trump y acabe por
darle las llaves de la casa blanca no sé
qué es lo que dice todo son ciertas pero
lo que hice me gusta así cuando las
elecciones de 2012 todos los analistas
coincidían en que es imposible ganar
unas elecciones sin el apoyo del voto
hispano y el afroamericano tram ha
demostrado que sólo es suficiente con
llegar a parte de el otro punto crucial
a favor de trump ha sido su mensaje anti
globalización que ha calado
especialmente en la zona de lo que se
conoce como ras velo o cinturón
industrial de hecho
hillary ha perdido en estados como
michigan wisconsin y pensilvania tres
estados que los demócratas no perdían
desde 1992 son zonas que se han visto
afectadas por la no adaptación de su
industria a la competencia internacional
y que han visto en él
curso proteccionista de trump un posible
futuro de esperanza pero para explicar
la victoria de trump también debemos
tener en cuenta la desmovilización
masiva del electorado demócrata en estas
elecciones
wikileaks filtró una serie de emails
enviados por john podestá el jefe de
gabinete de hillary clinton en estos
emails por esta señalaba la importancia
de mostrar a trump como un extremismo
todo lo que tenía que hacer el equipo de
campaña de clinton era dirigir a los
medios tradicionales para que cubrieran
y atacaran a donald trump ya que era la
estrella de las primarias republicanas
esta estrategia no ha servido más que
para incrementar las apariciones
públicas de trump de hecho si buscáis en
google trends veréis que el interés
suscitado entre el público por trump ha
sido considerablemente mayor que el
despertado por hillary sencillamente el
candidato republicano ha dominado la
campaña en todo momento se ha hablado de
sus propuestas los demócratas sólo se
han dedicado a reaccionar y es que a
diferencia de hillary clinton de cuyo
slogan nadie se acuerda donald trump ha
conseguido que todos tuviéramos en
nuestra cabeza sus mensajes hacer
américa grande de nuevo identificar a
hillary con el fraude la mentira
conseguir visualizar en la cabeza de
todo el mundo los cambios que va a
llevar a cabo nada más llegar al
gobierno
el muro romper el nafta enfrentas a
china hacer más barcos de guerra
en definitiva hillary ha optado por una
campaña tranquila y muy poco atractiva
es cierto que hilary se centró en captar
los millennials los jóvenes mediante
campañas digitales probablemente
tratando de convencer a los partidarios
de sanders pero se olvidó de centrarse
en aquellos más crecidos donde trump ha
sembrado su éxito pese a ello los
resultados han estado muy pero que muy
ajustados de hecho si miramos los votos
populares es decir el número de personas
que han votado a cada candidato
hillary estaría por encima sin embargo
el ista americano de colegios
electorales hace que trump sea el
vencedor final
y la pregunta es podemos aprender algo
de la campaña de donald trump vale
cualquier estrategia con tal de ganar
unas elecciones podéis dejarme vuestra
respuesta en los comentarios si no estás
viendo pero aún no está suscrito al
canal 'no que ahora mismo dando click a
este botón y si te ha gustado este
especial sos elecciones americanas dale
a like para hacérnoslo saber un saludo y
hasta el próximo vídeo